salut aujourd'hui je suis avec monsieur
jonathan bonjour alias as de pique et
qui à la base si vous connaissez pas de
piquer tu fais des vidéos de gaming tu
fais beaucoup de streams actes au match
et étaient toujours sur youtube exact a
tué un vieux tube un très très vite
utile qu'elle commençait youtube c'est
même pas qu'on faisait des vidéos sur
internet
bref aujourd'hui c'est un nouveau buzz
brain je crois que c'est que le
troisième de 2017 on a fait deux ou
trois l'année dernière cela c'est le
troisième de venu voir mon spectacle
c'est exactement
merci c'était parce qu'on est
actionnaire si vous voulez voir hamas
depuis que la semaine prochaine je serai
à lyon la semaine d'après à narbonne
après je sais qu'il ya du balance du
bardo plein de trucs comme ça c'est dans
la description allez-y c'est vachement
bien vraiment payé un petit peu sur la
tuque honoré vous ne venez pas dans la
vidéo on coupe ça
[Musique]
je me suis dit je vais inviter jonathan
à venir pour lui apprendre un maximum de
décimales de pi peut-être 30 tout ce
qu'il aime c'est rire tous les jours
douala va te servir à zain sur et vous
allez pouvoir le faire en même temps que
lui c'est le but des blues brain et en
même temps vous allez voir que même si
j'utilise mois plein de techniques
précises pour la mémoire que vous
pourrez retrouver sur les pistes de
mémoire on peut aussi en improvisé en
fait ne pas avoir forcément de technique
initiale et en improvisé pour retenir
une longue séquence de chiffres
ça peut être un numéro de téléphone qu
on vous donnait à la volée ça peut être
un code wifi ça peut être un code de
bitcoin de ce que tu veux en fait tu
vois marché avec les chiffres et les
lettres watch ouais ouais un peu quand
même être utile effectivement à quoi ça
peut être utile à rompre en pis pour
l'exemple quoi ça nous permet en plus de
faire une belle miniature peut-être clic
avec un titre puis ta clique tu vois
c'est pour ça puis les 80 premières des
semaines depuis sur les miniatures je
suis pas sûr que ça marche très bien
mais je t'apprendrai ce que ça donne
mais si lâchement bien frappé sa clique
pour ce qu'aiment les matins tu as
émirats pas où on va faire la première
séquence quand en images animées imagine
un quart et dans ce cas il ya une main
géante qui est posée est dans cette main
géante ya 1,9 prendre l'ensemble de la
route cet oeuf il ya 2 6 qui tourne pour
l'ouvrir comme un oeuf à la coque tu
veux mettre ton doigt que tu vas le
tremper un peu dans l'oeuf et tu vas te
faire une tâche dans le coup ça fait un
coup tâche d'accord ok ok ouais
jusqu'ici tout va bien
jusque là tout est ce que tu peux me
faire un récap de toute cette image rien
car qui arrive en ce cas il ya une main
qui tient un 9 7 9 en août 7 heures il y
a 2 6 qui coupe le sommaire une fois
qu'ils sont mais couper l'eau 30 mois et
je me fais un fauteuil pour moi un cas
c'est un cap qui à travers une main ça à
5 doit donc ça vaut 5 9 c1 9 1 2 1 2 une
6 1 6 et puis qui tâche
ça c'est juste pour avoir des consonnes
en tête si j'arrive toutes les voyelles
de coûts tâche s'affaisser tch
c'est 2 5 t de 3
ok c'est 2,5 hdmi ouais ok bien que wade
h et j'ai enlevé toutes les voyez
certains principes pour retenir le
suivant c'est toi qui aime proposer des
choses 89 ça t'inspire quoi mon année de
naissance au super 79
cette doxa bonne ouais et 9
car i 3 vous n'avez pas de chance parce
qu'il a une logique un peu comme la
mienne c'est hier une logique très
personnel au niveau des chiffres
terribles peut-être ouais ouais
et parce que si je te dis 8 4 6 ce que
ça te trouvais nos logiques 2004 6 8 4 6
mais moi je vous dis séquence médiatique
quoi huit studios sport de série 4 + 2
ça fait fi de la moitié ça fait 6 ou m6
10 à 6 lille / de plus de 4,6 ok alors
dans ces cas là on va essayer de créer
un truc assez rapidement il ya ton année
de naissance au départ ouais donc doc
seven qui t'offre un neuf carrés pour
ton anniversaire
il y avait une petite logique
progressive c'est à dire après il y
avait 2-3 qui suivent
et après on était sur le 8 4 6 du départ
de +2 est-ce que ça tu crois que tu
pourrais leur tenir de manière brute où
il faudrait quand même un petit truc
pour pour l'enfance 2 3 ça va aller pour
la séquence de suite vu de 4,6 je pense
qu'avec le 8 août reviendrait en fait si
on colle une image de 8 par exemple le
reste moyen utilisé par de plus de ça je
m'en souvenir pour caser le symbole de
l'infini quelque part
de 3 jusqu'à l'infini ouais ça peut se
faire de la même séquence par image
ok alors pour mon anniversaire d'auxerre
benoit m'offre un oeuf à 7h15 et donc
arrête 3 jusqu'à l'infini 8 4 6 ça
marche on peut tenter un dernier raid
aura 31 hockey ça marche
ouais alors on essaie ça je sais de voir
ce qui serait bon pour toi 64 plus oui
alors c'est ma console nintendo est
d'accord ok alors on en a deux deux
consoles
est-ce que c'est dieu 6 4 thon23 2-2 2-3
qui sut ça donnerait donc tu peux
imaginer le 3 mai 1,3 sur chaque console
si tu veux ah ouais ok ben le footix
l'imaginent une fois ça va t'aider
avec 3 manette chacune ouais donc ouais
voilà prêts aux manettes donc ta de
nintendo 64 avec chacune une boule de
billard écoute là sur le 8 on peut
partir sur un coup de billard bull
débrouille 1,8
t'imagines la boule de billard gérante
car il est qui dégomme complètement une
idée de ce que je le retrouve avec 30 de
sauvegarde et tu te retrouves avec la
moitié des contrôles coach et on revient
sur du 79 m qui n'avait rien d'accrocher
au départ on a vu les deux de frein neuf
donc et sont 900 mhz on continue
histoire c'est donc que vous avez
récupéré et je pense que tu peux juste
imaginer voilà de doc et son oeuf qui
apparaît pas par exemple qui c'est lui
qui va qui va stopper la boule de
billard de lottotech qui va de l'arrêter
ok donc dans la mécanique tu as les deux
consoles d une pelle de 64 la boule de
biens arrive avec les avec g3 dans la
neige la bulle de vie arrive elle
dégomme de les nintendo 64
donc j'ai 32 ans et c'est john qui a le
bout de ces jeux là un changement de
plan tu vois que c'est lui qui récupère
là avec son lot avec fondation adapté
aux requêtes aux quais voilà c'est parti
juste les images au temps où les chipies
commence par 3,1 4-1 5,9 de 6 5 3 5 8 y
ensuite 8,9
7 9 2 3 non non non non non 7 9 7 9 3
wii 2 3 8
4 6 exact 6 4 2 6 4 2 6 4 3 3 8 7 9
non j'aime bien un truc alors 8,3 de 7,9
oui tu viens me dire 31 chiffres de pino
pis ils te raser je pense en temps
d'apprentissage cure une dizaine de
minutes
tu vois des salles et ça fait 15 ans que
je connais les cinq premiers 1 14 15 9
et que j'ai pas eu si absolu de la suite
chapeau et la peau et tu vois et le truc
intéressant au final que jonathan qui
vous représente en fait là réussi à
faire c'est que on peut vraiment retenir
n'importe quelle séquence en fait si on
y trouve un jeu de mémoire sans chercher
une technique particulière précise est
organisée juste une histoire voilà mais
des choses qui vous parle avouent le
meilleur moyen de passer en souvenir
c'est d'essayer de l'apprendre par coeur
et le meilleur moyen de s'en souvenir
c'est de vous faire confiance dans
l'imaginaire et d'essayer de faire
quelque chose de bizarre d'être pour les
autres mais personnellement qui va
fonctionner il suffit là une séquence
comme ça si tu te la répète tous les
jours pendant une semaine
une fois dans la journée elle va tenir
et puis après une fois par semaine et
puis voilà et puis ça va ça va resté
sérieux moi ok à un moment donné tu
serais même étonné c'est que tu vas même
pu repasser par les images les chiffres
ils vont devenir
et tu sais en fait oui à fortiori on
s'assoit mais au fond de toi dans des
synapses des neurones c'est toujours
relié à tout ce système dit najm et
amman plus besoin de passer par là c'est
assez rigolo voiture merci mec
bah merci à tous d'être prête allégeance
peur j'espère que ça va vous motiver à
essayer de faire ça et que ça vous
aidera à retenir les mots de passe wifi
ou je ne sais quoi qui vous connaissez
pas la chaîne de jonathan je vous mets
le lien juste ici il est entre nous deux
ça c'est pour s'abonner à ma chaîne à
moi c'est juste là vous pouvez cliquer
la vidéo si vous souhaitez et à très
bientôt
ciao ciao
[Musique]